I make history means he's partly gonna
do that
ha if it is need less a mycelium it you
are throwing a security card off this
Armand stare 12 you're like oh then I
look down I see one of Jaws me it's and
your does that mean yeah so you have
been training yes I've been trying quite
a bit have you doing a [__] on a train
I've seen so far in a year yeah just lay
in this kid out not in something yeah
I'm like all right he's definitely
learning how's it been for you it's been
I'd say it's been tough like I've been
through a lot a lot of times like
especially with cardio I've just there's
so many times I've been like I should
just stop here but then I just think of
jail and then it pushes me harder and
harder and I just keep pushing more and
more and more and just trying to get as
fit as possible and then even with the
sparring in the boxing like here and
there I I mess up and I don't get it
right but then I just keep training I
keep trying to keep training to the
point where I'm like I enjoy it while
you boxing it out like it's crazy like I
remember when I first when my first
sparring session I was against give he
absolutely [__] me up and I like after
that session else I hate this boxing
thing how am I gonna do this this is
this is horrible but like with me like I
never give up I'm always like okay I'm
not getting this right now I can't get
good at it
so how can I get from this point to that
point and it's just through hard work
and I've just been yeah
the one thing I'm picking up listen you
are in jokers oh yeah yeah and this is
one thing that a lot of people say is if
you can learn to do something you can
learn to do everything because you
understand the concept of learning and
with YouTube the dedication that you
showed which in the early days before
everyone knew that the money value you
knuckle down and you made sure you were
the best
right and you were the best like you
you've made your mark there's no one who
can take away from you
then do you feel like you've applied
those sort of principles to boxing and
yeah exactly like a lot of people don't
realize like you know there's a reason
why I have 17 million subscribers on
YouTube
so like I'm obviously just gonna take
that same concept and put it into
everything similar music same of acting
same with doing making a book like
everything I do I put my all into it to
make sure I book I become the best at it
so so when when you did have that first
bad day yeah you walk home and you're
like I got my ass kicked yeah yeah I
know it was thinking about job but you
obviously had dig deeper than just jaw
yeah what what is it that got you
through the sort of immediate hard
bitter training like and what was that
like going through those lessons you've
got a trainer who's Team GB level train
yeah yeah and what was it like being put
through Isis with our with our IDs yeah
he is a tough trainer like he pushes you
like pushes you to the point where most
people would be like this is ridiculous
like you how you gonna do this but
that's where you get the best results
and he's just been pushing me for months
man he's just been making me work way
more than I thought I could ever work
and I think he's he's helped me load
he saw me loads and he's like he shown
me like my level like what what now I
can get to that make sense and I think
it's just showing inspiring a lot of
times out spar people who have been
training boxing for like years and then
I'll follow them and then I just slapped
them up and uh as soon as I saw that I
remember the first time I saw it I was
just like dude this is sick like the guy
beat was like he just felt like [__]
because obviously like you're the
YouTuber miss your lumps yeah a YouTube
guy and everyone just hog it on you you
want to look good against you exactly
it's like ah you got beat by case I the
fee for YouTube it doesn't make sense
but it's because I just I just work so
hard man and one thing you've talked
about when you first come in there
you've got you feel like you've got a
natural ability in this to it yeah 100%
in terms of power especially mm-hmm and
I've seen one video where this kid is
coming after you and he's really was I
mean he didn't have the head gear on but
it's not that that matters
yeah yeah he's trying to me yeah yeah
yeah and you clip them which is over the
side of the head he stumbles into the
cage and they're nuture yeah great
leather flap letting them thing is like
I'll admit with that one with that point
the video everyone's talking about when
I did it I was shook I was so sure
because I've never got that way I'm
sorry but in the middle of the chaos oh
yeah you didn't look shook you can [__]
you look like a [__] cold hard kill
on me okay oh yeah no I was until I
knocked him out yeah then I was sure I
was just like well why done I felt like
that killed someone it was creamy yeah
it was face down all the scientists
that's worse I mean Vidal was just like
yo you've got that natural power but he
could tell even when I would you know it
did my first sparring is just like
you've got the power so we don't need to
work on that it's like we need work on
is your movement and your speed because
speed kills and that's why I'm going to
show on Saturday speed kills
so based on a three obviously I watched
early sparring out I'm gonna I've been
watching fighting for 20 years yeah and
I did think needs to work on the speed
you look at law and I just say yeah yeah
and you look a lot leaner yeah yeah is
this all part of yeah what I said so I
know I'm pretty sure Joe has been
bulking up whereas for me I've just been
kind cutting kinda good for me
speed is everything I don't need to work
on power like I haven't worked on power
at all really huh because I know I've
already got that so I've just been
working to make sure I'm fast enough to
dodge his punches and punch them at the
same time one thing I notice is you give
an interview while you do a podcast on
the sidemen channel where you said I'm
gonna knock about I'm finishing a myth
this is you actually seem quite copy
yeah yeah of course yeah this is gonna
be easy
yeah it is people don't realize this is
really very easy really
yeah how is he talking like what amount
of rounds that you're
I said round three or four yeah like I
doubt it'll go the distance a lot of
people think it's gonna go this no where
are you getting this conference from is
it the power or is it other things I
think it's just how hard I've been
training and I think the people I've
been sparring as well like I haven't
been sparring easy people
I've been sparring people who I've been
like 95 kg like weight heavier than Joe
could ever be people who have been
faster than like Joe could ever be as
well and I just what I might to my
advantage and just I guess I I know what
the like I've been through the worst if
that make sense so for me to fight Joe
it's like easy that's why I just why are
you because some people might be sitting
there thinking you're underestimate and
jaw why do you look at jaws so weak in
your mind I hate these people
I for me I just I just don't feel joke
and especially cardio-wise do you think
the nails in the shoe is on the knee is
definitely definitely been an issue for
him but I feel like cardio-wise I just
Trump him like really yeah I think six
rounds is nothing to me literally I
could do 9 10 11 rounds and I don't
think he can do that like I saw him
which he released a video of him
screaming on the bike like I haven't
touched the bike I've been running
running by constantly constantly running
and to make sure my cardio is 100% and
people will see like I do round 1 and
I'll look fresh round 2 fresh round 3
fresh and Joe will just slowly get
slower and slower and slower and you
just realized Joe can handle my pace
I'll just be constantly on him and I
think that's where I feel like Joe is
just gonna still go and that's why I'm
just so confident because I know like my
stamina is 100% what puts me apart from
everyone else
but everyone I sparred struggles after
around 2/3 they're like how is this kid
still going then they that's when
mentally they just crumble
they just did they're just like I handle
this anymore and they just give up what
have your trainer said about how they
think you've done in this small period
of time without things this is this is
ridiculous
yeah he's like this this doesn't
normally happen like from where I was to
get to now is ridiculous like I'm
finding people who want to go pro and
I'm like I like and like I'm making a
hard for them and he's just there like
obviously near work on a few things here
and there but like ultimately I do it
like everyone's everyone I sponsors
you've got nothing to worry about you're
sick and this is this is insane and you
you've got the stamina as well like
you've just got the whole packet and the
power it's like so that's why I'm just
very calm you feel like a natural at
this
yeah 100 it's a kind of way I feel like
I maybe in the past life I was a box or
something like I don't know maybe I'm
just talking out my ass but what if you
are then what cuz there is some people
out there thinking what what if what if
you go in the first round and I don't
know you get hit with a shot and you
think [__] me hmm I mean I'm in trouble
yeah
do you feel like you've been hit enough
heavy hearted when you've tested
yourself yeah yeah I I've been in the
ring with guys who hit hard
litchi I did two rounds of this guy
who's a Maitai champion and he like I
don't know if you know about my type or
everything is my tyre designed to be
powerful yeah so two rounds of that
three minutes and literally I took the
most beat led the biggest shot I've ever
taken in my life and I still stood I
didn't drop at one point and like at
that moment I was like okay I can take
this I'm a fighter and like even but I
was impressed and without was like to
Leon destroy him two rounds kill jday to
the point like I want to see him drop
him and these Ricky was giving me shots
to drop me and I didn't drop and at that
point I was like like that session
sucked because he's yeah trust me a dude
like I remember after
his life just feel so I feel so [__] you
know I mean like well the eagle is
growing through the training yeah yeah
my mom yeah yeah yes yes exactly
Southside dude but anyone but then but
then it's like I've been through the
worst and now I'm still yeah I'm still
here so if I can do that then nothing
can scare me and that's why I'm just so
ready for Saturday like because people
still see me as that FIFA a gaming
youtuber that's it well you don't see
yourself that way no no no and to be
honest to you I can see a massive
difference in you Yanis because yeah I
think when you haven't and this isn't
they're not on you as a man you know you
were lucky in life yeah you are you
played a computer game life took off for
you
good luck yes right yeah but you didn't
go through hard times like other people
have been through and yours have been
manufactured now and you've ended up
putting yourself down yeah and now
you're gonna find out what the [__]
you're made of yeah and what you'll find
out is actually if I hadn't have been
lucky in life I would have been all
right because I've been getting up after
getting punched and do you feel like
people have had one image of you and
you've had that sort of similar image of
yourself but now you're sort of finding
out a lot more about who you are as a
man I feel like 100 sin it's it's
changed a lot about me like I didn't
think I had this in me 100% like I'd be
the kid I'd never really get into fights
here and there I would have I call it
[__] moments so this is why just rage
and righteous I've only ever had it like
three times so twice in school and then
once with Joe when he pushed me right so
we must have you on my podcast I
remember we're talking about a lot who
just would not [__] go away in a
nightclub yeah and he was right in your
face and then yeah and you said at the
time body God kept me bodyguard hmm do
you think now would be like whoa the
biggest thing is like it's kind of weird
you said that so I think nowadays
whenever like it's kind of like I kind
of want someone to start on me is I
don't know every it's kind of bad I
don't think that's so
if you've just gotten this almost
superpower and yeah yeah yeah but I know
I've been do like come at me I'm just
there like okay yes
speaking from as an older likely yeah
yeah a big lad who can handle themselves
that'll go away yeah yeah yeah
especially if you go in there and do
what you say you're gonna do in a few
days so in terms of everyone around you
obviously very close mates yeah your
family yeah I mean your mom like what
are these people thinking about your
about setting the ring um they're not
worried a lot like Simon looked at he's
frightened that you're not capable of
doing what you say you're gonna do but
you just when one of your close friends
our family get in the room
one of my best mates used to do
regularly you're [__] yourself like
yeah of course of course cuz you don't
know but the thing is like I know and I
think that's the most important thing if
I know then I'm like no one no one to
anything to be worried about I keep
telling everyone like I've got this like
it's and it's not like I'm overconfident
it's not like I'm trying to lie to
myself I know I've got this because I've
put in the work and that's just it so
I'm not saying you're overconfident cuz
I believed everything you said you've
been through you yeah yeah yeah however
hmm like recently there was a UFC
heavyweight title fight and I remember I
watched an interview with the Challenger
Francis these verses in the corner
things with in Ghana like I didn't do
cardio no but I'm not like but maybe
this is why well the last round that's
the first round he just went in swinging
but like a madman huh and then I mean he
caught he caught me a few times but the
point is when I watched his interview
yeah and then I watch your interview oh
and I was sitting there thinking who's
the [__] pro because you with no
fights yeah more confident than um I was
10 knockouts in his last 10 fights oh so
I think you are you're extremely
confident and I'm not saying you're
overconfident cuz you might go in and do
with it but [__] me me you are
yeah I don't know if you realize how
confident yeah I know I I know a lot of
people gonna see this and be like I
really hope you get knocked out what do
you say to those people wait till
Saturday the thing like Joe Joe O'Neill
to hit me as many times as he wants to
hear me that's it and that is I mean
there's a reason why I've been cutting
that's all I'm saying
yeah you feel like you're gonna be light
on your feet very like yeah my footwork
is on point on point like he's going to
have to like come at me because if he
wants to just fight like that's not
happening I'm gonna box him I'm going to
box into there and then Jordan soon as
in his interview with us because I'm
sure you'll watch it yeah his
inspiration is Mike Tyson yeah oh my
gosh so that's the thing that lends to
what you're sort of suggesting you know
I trained for this I've let you trained
four or five months for this we knew
what he was going to do like if he
wanted to box me he was going to lose so
he had to come at me like Mike Tyson and
then we just trained to make sure when
he does he just gets slapped up
constantly
and then he'll get frustrated and won't
know what to do and why he's getting for
Sharon doesn't know what to do he's
getting slapped and slapped and flat on
till we just wears him down where's him
down and then he's got nothing left
and then I knock him out what's your
thoughts about him as a person are you
still kind I don't [__] with him well
yeah I'm sorry I don't [__] with him no
I know after what he tried to do to me
yeah well you know I was in on the whole
mental health thing yeah trying to put
words in my mouth yeah and not let the
bad yeah I pissed me off am I'm sorry
like no no you don't just do that that's
that that's our border right before he
was just were just boxing that's it
uh-huh and then he tried to just have a
touch my whole career I
what do you feel like that could have
gone really bad for very bad and it did
it's still be in the low composure yeah
yeah it's a peon nightmare and I'm just
saying like why we're just meant to be
fighting that's it why are you trying to
make this into something it isn't and
then I seen seed outside now and then he
pushed me as well in front of all those
people trying to make me look like a
[__] alright now I'm not gonna let you
get away with that so yeah he'll get
what's coming to him and I can't wait I
can't wait so this is this is deadly
oh yeah there's so many people I said oh
yeah alright so W I mean I was I was you
know yeah I was like that's not [__]
fake yeah yeah it's [__] them of course
the guy yeah the guy's alright anyway
but ya know Jojo is yeah he's well the
thing is when you first went in there
there's a lot of people who when they
first start boxing like Ricky Gervais
said a charity boxing match and it took
me adjust to just get used to punching
someone in hurtin them and yeah because
it's not a sport in the mind it's like
you fight out of anger
yeah did that come easy to you were you
quite ruthless with it because I when I
seen you not like you know you look
ruthless it took a while for me to get
to that point I remember when I hit
someone even my train house I didn't hit
him because I was like oh man like you
don't step yeah I was just like you know
like with whistle friends and you know
like I want my doing like to probably
like try here but I eventually like the
more you train the more you that comes
out of you and then you realize okay
what does switch on is it off if you
catch Joe yes but like you say you're
going to mhm and he staggers the way
this kid did yeah are you gonna because
the difference is that kid was just a
face using yeah yeah you didn't know him
yeah yeah we know you would Joe spent a
lot of time together in the past are you
gonna pull the trigger I mean you were
best friends but oh really look nice
friend I know you mean you were mates we
were come on
you paid for the guy to go on holiday
yeah because no one else wanted to go
with me I had to pick Eliot
and Joe so you you're saying to me
you're not gonna struggle to pull the
trigger no no the law I'm going to put
all my power into that and make sure
he's knocked out that's that's a plan
yeah I can't wait I that's rich I can't
wait till Saturday
yeah I can't wait till Wednesday to show
what I'm about to show I can't wait till
Friday to see his stupid little face and
then I can't wait till Saturday to knock
him out that's the plan and I can't wait
100 when when this was all settled for
some reason you instantly became the bad
guy even before Joe said what he said
about you you've said mental health and
whatever the way you're talking now it's
almost like your embrace and that's all
are you aware of that are you go of
course you cool about this fighted like
I know I'm going to get booed this
scenes again which would get to Irene of
course I can't wait to not go out and
then it'd be like where's the booze now
like that I'm just I'm just so ready man
I'm just so ready like nothing can faze
me
this one this one bother you having like
8,000 people booing and I've I've like I
know how to just cancel that fallout I
know it's the last press conference yeah
as I was to be honest me i'ma put all
these people this I'm not used to this
yeah you perform it for yeah yeah so I
won't say like I've performed in front
of people who just are not interested
yeah yeah like you just despise me and
like it's still common I still perform
and I do I need to do like it's it's
nothing
it won't face I think it will
underestimate you mentally yeah that's
what I realized when I was up on that
stage all right you've got your [__]
together yeah no come on line come on
better than that yeah I've been doing
this with too long what what is your
favorite part of this boxing journey
that you've been on when you look back
at it I'd say my aside from the fight I
think I'd say my figure yeah because
it's making me gay girls
[Laughter]
really yeah on the level yeah one inside
yeah cause like it's sick yeah to be
failed last time yeah last time I seen
you you like literally you look like
you've never trained you just look like
yeah yeah good and now do you think
you're gonna curry on the box yes 100%
yes I love it love it no I have another
fight yes one who said I want to oh well
a few people you're gonna alright of
course you're already planning this yeah
yeah I've already planned the speech and
everything really yeah I really know I
won this I just saw it's like I just
need to prove the people that I can be
Joe entirely that's it yeah [__] me yeah
that's why I can't wait would be will
see me on Saturday twice alright what's
your least favorite bit of the boxing
trainer not being least favorite bit
you've been dieting like [__] I I guess
the food yeah I guess the food so I mean
because I've got chef so that's its I
guess it's helped but it's like the food
I've got to eat is quite boring it's
boring yeah so it's lots of greens fish
chicken which I like I like fish and
chicken buy me like the amount greens I
have to eat and just a lot of stuff that
it's just your 4k I'm about 84 kg right
now yeah which is shocking because I
thought the size surface is going to be
massive and when asked jaw I'm gonna
show jaw was in about 80 - oh really
we're talking literally four pounds five
pounds yeah yeah nothing yeah that is
that would actually make use able to
fight each other in a profession yeah
which is annoying because because I had
had without head guards mmm which would
have made things even easier it slice it
this thing isn't it I'm just I'm
surprising you really know because
sometimes I look back at your first
videos we've all seen them where you
were this little geek playing yeah now
you're looking like a [__] stone-cold
killer
it's a it's a little different
I'm saying but I go through a lot so
that's why it's come from yeah what is
the main what's the main reason that you
feel like you're gonna win this fight if
there was one reason that stuck out
speed kills
speed kills speed kills nice one yeah
people are looking at YouTube after
especially after the login poll and all
everyone's looking for reasons to [__]
into hey Yugi yes especially after the
press conference people that was what
the mainstream wanted they wanted two
young idiots going at it and now what
they want is for you to look like [__]
in the boxing ring people are praying
for it yeah how do you feel they're
gonna look at you guys after this fight
I feel like that will still be people
who are just gonna complain anyway
saying it's [__] that two youtubers
up in a boxing match selling out the
copper box and you could have sold out
three copper box but yeah yeah I think
we could have done oh - yeah like we
yeah I'd say we could have done the
madness but you know it's it's quite a
lot to hire out the weather what's good
so you don't you don't think the
perceptions going to change that much
then um I think I think I love you like
it will change a lot of people's minds
cuz when youtubers yeah me personally I
really want you guys to migrate and
they're the Perrier's yeah and I guess
you think that one of you is a looker in
there yeah yeah yeah but I mean like
like I said I still want to do more like
and I think this will hopefully allow me
to do more like that's what I want I'm
looking at you and I I feel like such a
[__] multi-faceted person now you got
the YouTube Diaz looking but FIFA and
then grew up into an entity enough yeah
music yeah and then after box and no
anything you can't [__] turn you on
only I die
I kind of like I guess I look up to
people like how this can be now and like
Will Smith and those people who Jamie
Foxx them yeah you above everything yeah
so your subscribers
yes how do you think they look at you
differently because you took a massive
break this year and yet
music and you came up in the odd video
but this has been your quiet as year
2017 yeah and now you're going to be
back and in the biggest event in youtube
history yeah how do you think they're
gonna look you the ones the diehards who
really do love you and care about you
and what do you think they like about I
think I'll bring back a lot a load of
old fans you have a hello old fans who
have got older yeah we'll look at this
and be like oh I can I can invest for
some of them they probably look here but
you've been through some ups and downs
yeah you know I know yeah some of the
things you've done
yeah interesting things you get in the
ring and you put in a [__] real
training company it's kinda like I'm a
serious person actually that's it's kind
of then gonna be hard not to be a fan of
me and that's what I mean like if you if
you see someone that used to be a fan of
not someone else out just clean and he
looked like a boxer it's kind of like
that's kind of cool yes it's like see
what you want about them but look at
that look at ya he's gotten those took
himself seriously people wrong and
that's not sort of you I Drive ya 110
and like I think a lot of my drivers
what people have been saying about me
like ah you know you're fat you've got
man boobs and all this nor that that's
why I can't wait til Friday for the
woods were way away dude
when people see me they're gonna be like
Oh Joe might be in trouble you've caused
yeah so for this is for you it's not
just about jaws about proving everyone
yeah if we will everyone that you know
like you can you know you can say
whatever you want I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna listen to it I'm gonna do what I
want to do I make it work for me all
right well good luck me up I'll be there